How good-looking is my wife?
Not everyone was thrilled with the gown First Lady Michelle Obama wore to the Inaugural Balls...
...but most fashion critics have been enthusiastic about her flair for fashion.
That media attention...
...reminds Mary Tomer of another First Lady.
I think there is a certain way we feel about Michelle Obama...
...that we haven't felt about a First Lady since Jacqueline Kennedy.
That's what inspired Tomer to launch her blog,...
"Mrs. O".
It led to the publication of her book,...
..."Mrs. O: The Face of Fashion Democracy".
The blog features an update nearly every day...
...with what the First Lady was last seen wearing.
It averages 10,000 hits a day...
...with visitors from more than 200 countries.
And I think they're just inspired to see a very...
...kind of modern, fashion forward,...
...normal woman in this fantastic role on platform.